why don't governments help build more
small businesses it's a question i got
from one of my
newsletter readers charles right why
doesn't the government help small
business to create new markets this is a
a huge topic and can get into a lot of
detail but at the core for me is yes i
think governments can be more involved
can be more helpful can have more
programs entrepreneurs are the ones who
are shaping our economy who are giving
new jobs who are helping countries and
cities gain a competitive edge over
every other country and city right
that's going to drop people draw
investment draw money
and you can vote with your with your
vote right you can choose which
government you want to bring in by
voting for the right person and for the
right party
but at the end of the day
it's not on the government to do this
that's really macroeconomic thinking
it's on you
you go out and do this you go out and
make your city better you go out and
make your country better
you can't wait for the government to
give you something to help you get
started
okay if you look at the successful
entrepreneurs how they got started every
famous entrepreneur you could think of
look at how many of them got huge
government back in the start
nobody it's the entrepreneurs who are
the lifeblood and you can't let
no government support
as being your reason for not getting
started
it's not it's not a good enough reason
it's a limiting personal belief i did a
presentation in brunei
and it takes them six months
to set up a business and a bank account
six months if you have an idea for
business you want to get started their
government is so restrictive that it
takes you six months to get this thing
started and i was blown away because for
me
i could have a business and a bank
account set up
one day and i'm in business and i got to
get to work and their entrepreneurs were
still hungry and were still pushing
through even though there's tons of red
tape they were still making it happen
for themselves because that was in them
that was their fire you have so many
advantages
to start a business
you have your chance to create your path
to create your own freedom to make the
changes that you want to see in the
world you could start making that happen
today you could start on a small scale
you can have a big vision and work
towards it but it's not on the
government to make that happen and yes
you can vote you can get involved you
can volunteer you can donate money to
the people who you think can make this
happen
i'm not saying
uh government whatever i don't care be
apathetic
i love governments to get involved they
should do more but it's not an excuse
for you not getting started if you're
not following your dream if you're not
making an impact and following your
passion
at the end of the day it's on you
and you have to throw away any limiting
belief you have
and and there's so many
entrepreneurs right into me and say i
can't start until the government does
something or because i'm too young or
i'm too old or i'm an immigrant or i'm a
woman or i'm disabled or i don't have
the money or whatever whatever the
reason is it's not a real reason because
you can't have success with any of those
issues they're non-issues
it's not on anybody else
to come and fix you
if you want to see a change you go out
and you make that happen
and you bring on people who believe in
the same thing and you create a movement
and you start really impacting your city
and your country and you can be the one
to start bringing in dollars and
investment and customers and business
and commerce all of that you can lead
that
so go out and vote
vote for the people who you believe in
donate to their campaigns you think
they're going to do a good job
but take some personal accountability
yourself get involved
build a great company
and make your city and your country
better yourself it's on you
believe
you guys like this video please give it
a thumbs up below always makes me want
to do more and please leave a comment
let me know what you think let me know
what you want to see you have a question
leave it below i'll make a video
response thank you so much and i'll see
you soon
you